[Music]
as enterprises digitally transform
themselves networks are at the
foundation while networks are constantly
modified to support your applications
you need a single pane of glass that can
address all aspects of troubleshooting
and monitoring so you can easily
diagnose complex connectivity and
network performance issues network
intelligence Center is Google clouds
framework for network monitoring across
the cloud and on-premise it improves
user experience security and operations
by providing a comprehensive platform
for network monitoring verification and
optimization across the cloud and data
center firewall insights is a module in
network intelligence center that helps
you optimize firewall rule configuration
tighten up network security boundaries
and detect abnormal traffic patterns
large enterprises often have thousands
sometimes tens of thousands of firewall
rules configured by different groups
over time the large number of rules
becomes unmanageable and introduces all
kinds of security risks and operation
overhead the firewall insights module
helps you tackle these challenging
problems I'll walk you through a few use
cases where you can leverage these new
functionalities to optimize your VPC
firewall configuration as firewall rules
are added by different people at
different times new rules can be
accidentally shadowed by existing rules
and as a result fail to take effect
without automated detection it's very
hard for you to catch this when managing
a large number of firewall rules
configured for the same VPC suppose I
have added a rule to allow traffic from
ten 1.0.0 forward / 24 subnet to access
web app - when I go to VM 1 in the
source subnet with IP as 10.10 - and try
to reach vm 2 tagged with web app - it
fails to find out why I'll go to the
network detail page for VM - here are
two rules applied to this traffic the
deny rule blocking traffic from 10.10 0
/z means is shadowing the allow rule
that allows traffic from a sub range
10.10
zero forward slash 24 to avoid such
incidents in the future you want to
proactively clean up your firewall
configurations and automatically
identify all firewall rules accidentally
overshadowed by other rules firewall
insights and Network intelligence Center
provides you with a convenient list of
rules overshadowed by other firewall
rules a rule can be either overshadowed
by a single or a combination of multiple
rules in this case the rule allowing
traffic on both port 8080 and 443 is
overshadowed by a combination of to deny
rules blocking HTTP and HTTPS traffic
respectively you can review each
shadowed role in site detail and adjust
the rule settings to match your
application traffic control needs in
this second scenario I'll show you the
allowed rules with no hit insight to
help you clean up your allow rules
leftover from past projects and tighten
up your security boundaries to find out
what these unnecessary allowed rules are
I'll go to the firewall insights in the
network intelligence Center on the allow
rules with no hit card I see a list of
firewall rules that I have not been hit
by any traffic in the last six weeks we
notice that there is a rule for allowing
Internet traffic to an app in a test
project web app one that the project
owner forgot to clean up the firewall
insights module automatically detects
such leftover allowed rules so that you
can get the opportunity to clean it up
using firewall insights you can not only
identify problems in your firewall rule
configuration but also obtain visibility
into abnormal traffic patterns that you
want to get alerted to deny roll with
hits helps you capture the traffic
blocked by the deny rules and detect
external attacks or misbehaving VMs in
your cloud deployment from the list you
can easily drill down to the
corresponding firewall logs to review
and find out where the denied traffic
came from in summary firewall insights
automatically detects overlapping and
misconfigured rules to help you maintain
the right set of firewall rules that
protect your cloud deployment and brings
real-time visibility to your firewall
utilization statistics
you
[Music]